the yale school of medicine uh kindly uh
loaned this uh uh uh
auditorium to the yale school of public
health for our event
uh with governor ned lamont and mayor
justin ellicker
it's my pleasure as dean of the school
of public health my name is sten vermond
to
introduce the president of our
university
peter salabe is the 23rd president in
yale's history
and although his primary appointment is
in psychology
we're very proud to call him yale school
of public health
uh faculty member because he has a
secondary appointment for many many
years
in our school as well not only that but
the first lady of yale
marta moret is a graduate of our school
so we feel we have an inn
in the president's office although
that's just sort of a feeling not a
reality
because the president serves the entire
university
so on that note peter we are going to
turn it over to you
for your greeting and introduction of
our panelists today
well thank you
great to see our panelists and
i know many of you are watching on the
zoom or youtube and
uh marta who you just mentioned that is
one of them
uh she and i are very proud of our
associations with the
yale school of accounting to all the
school of public health students
uh welcome to a new and certainly
extraordinary
uh academic year i'm just so grateful
that we can
pursue with you uh our mission of
education
search practice we're doing that
partly in person and and mostly remotely
but
i'm glad we are all now and this
semester
and the reason why we can be
so aggressive in pursuing
education and research in this
challenging time
is because of the strong leadership of
governor ned lamont
the support and open communication
between their teams and
experts working at yale indonesian
across the state has been phenomenal
and i am just so so grateful to the two
of them
and to everyone else who has been
making it possible to keep our campus
our city and our region and our state
uh safe all of
that good work includes exemplary
uh an exemplary report and and wonderful
ongoing work uh
from the reopen connecticut advisory
group
and that work has benefited from
contributions by
members of the elk community some of
whom are with us
uh today we've been able together to
significantly
reduce communal transmission of coven 19
since the peak in april and as we work
and as we study together this semester
we know that we share a responsibility
to maintain and encourage
uh what is a positive health
uh positive public health situation
relatively speaking in our state
so today you will be hearing from the
leaders
who have contributed immeasurably to the
health improvements in our region
and in our state and it is my honor to
introduce them to you
governor ned lamont has served
communities in connecticut
as a business founder and as a volunteer
teacher
and through multiple roles in public
service
he became the 89th governor of the state
of connecticut
in 2019 mayor justin ellicker grew up in
this state and earned his
mba from the yale school of management
and a masters in environmental
management
from the yale school of the environment
after years of working in public service
he was sworn in
as the 51st mayor of new haven at the
beginning
of this year albert koh
is a co-chair of the reopen connecticut
advisory group and he is the chair of
the department of epidemiology
of microbial diseases and a professor of
epidemiology
and of medicine engineering
is co-chair of the reopened connecticut
advisory group
board co-chair of advance connecticut
and
former ceo of pepsico
she earned her master's degree from the
yale school of management
and has served as a yale trustee
marissa bond is the director of health
for the city of new haven she served and
led in the public health sector
for over 18 years thank you all for
being with us today and it is my
pleasure to now
turn things over to mayor ellaker uh to
speak
thank you all for being here and thank
you panelists especially
thank you uh peter for those kind
opening remarks um
and i i obviously thank you to
so many of the people on stage for the
work that you've been doing to help
support
all of our residents around the state
and in new haven to keep us healthy
we've been doing pretty well we've been
doing pretty well and that's um
in large part because we've been clear
on following the science following the
research
and our residents around the state have
overwhelmingly been cooperating
in mass wearing social distancing and
following the so many
guidelines and when you think about the
importance
of the many students that are part of
the yale school of public health
and the many new students and the
journey you're going to be embarking on
now is a time more than ever when
your goals your passions your mission
is underscore the importance of it is
underscored and the kind of
impact that you can have on the health
and well-being of
everyone i'm sure that has not been lost
on you as you have experienced in
so many ways i'm sure around the u.s and
around the world
with this pandemic but
i want to encourage you and i presume
that many of you
particularly those students that are in
the school of public health
are interested in the public service
component of this
but the public service component of your
your education while you are here and
beyond that
is vital to keeping people alive
and especially in these times when
we look at the inequities that have been
so rawly exposed by coven 19
and that have been highlighted even more
by the protests around the nation
i urge you to think deeply about
your role in addressing those inequities
it's there's exciting possibilities but
it's also
critical that we push ourselves to think
out of the box to be open to criticism
and to think deeply about how our
personal
roles and the organizations we represent
can play
a a have a significant impact on
addressing
so many inequalities that exist i'm
grateful to have the opportunity to be
here
and stan am i supposed to turn it over
to the governor now
that's right governor lamont
good morning and um peter i like that
halo like rainbow in your background
that's a divine it gives us a little bit
of hope
and justin thank you as um justin said
um
we're following the science but it's not
without irony that um
indra justin and i all graduated from
yale school of management josh jabal
who's here with us who helped oversee
the state's response working with the
scientific community yale school of
management
um we could have had a couple more folks
from uh public health
uh i think you are at the right place at
the right time
and really happy that you're here and
hope that some of you stick around
um so to follow the science of course i
needed dr albert co
and maritza to help lead the way and
so i'll just start as a governor um
you know what you know and you you know
what you don't know and uh i came into
this job as the first business guy
in um you know decades and i come out of
telecommunications so
if you want to know what i was thinking
about in terms of
um you know outside of jobs the economy
and budget uh what was going to be the
big iceberg what we were really worried
about what could hit us um
probably given my background i was
really worried about
a cyber attack and uh you know we get
pinged virtually every day hundreds of
times
and i saw um you know municipalities and
the such getting hit up
uh you know for ransomware and the such
and uh so that's what
that was the very first emergency test
that we ran through
our emergency operations center which is
uh right next to the state capitol
and um what was
helpful about it was i also had to reach
out to all my fellow governors
because we realized that a lot of the
threats being
rising tide cyber germ
knew no borders so i got to know um
as part of that process governor cuomo
governor baker new york
massachusetts rhode island and new
jersey and that served us pretty well
as we began hearing about um
uh covet the virus and then things
happen really quickly um you know josh
and i were
you know hearing a little bit about
wuhan and what was going on
we went uh to the um i went to the
governor's association meeting down in
washington d.c
that was probably in late january barely
mentioned
um what was happening there what we did
have was a secretary of defense
mike pompeo and he said whatever you do
have nothing to do
with the chinese because every time you
get a gift from the chinese
it comes with strings attached and i
want to make sure
uh and i i reference that because you'll
see
what happened soon thereafter you know
from there um
from there we saw what was going on at
wuhan and then seattle
and then new rochelle we were paying
attention
the virus was getting closer and then it
was a
saturday night in early march
that we got the call uh a nurse at
danbury hospital
was the first connecticut infection that
we could identify
and uh a shiver went up the spine
and all of a sudden it wasn't overseas
it wasn't over there
it was right here and
there all the training you've had in our
case management your case
public health um you got to reach out
for the best
and the brightest uh first thing we had
to do was within a week we called the
state of emergency
that gave us a little more authority and
power to make decisions quickly
i couldn't have the legislature in
session because it was um
obviously risky having 187 people under
under
that dome
you know within a week or so thereafter
we closed down high school basketball
and schools and then it really
came home what was going on
and it was in and around at that point
that um
we began thinking about look i i saw
what was happening in
queens not to mention um other places
where the hospitals were getting
overwhelmed so
um first thing josh and i had to do when
it comes to reaching out the experts we
reached out to the hospital community
here uh in the state of connecticut
and to be a blunt um we had had the
state had a lousy relationship with the
hospitals in fact they were suing each
other for the last 10 years
fortunately we had put that behind us
and when we reached out we said we need
you
uh you maybe remember back then it was
flatten the curb make sure we don't have
that
surge that could overwhelm our icus
overwhelm our hospitals like we saw in
italy like we saw in
queens and i'm
we worked together really closely with
marner here at yale new haven hartford
hospital
um nuveen and and it made a difference
and all of a sudden our hospitals were
working together as one
and when stanford hospital was being
overwhelmed and greenwich hospital was
being overwhelmed
because the virus was marching like an
army from
the greater new york metro area right up
the metro north
corridor and the southern fairfield
county and danbury were the first to get
hit
and at that point we had hartford health
and others you know bringing down the
troops bringing down what spare mass we
could find
with spare vents we were all terrified
about shortage events at that time we've
learned a lot
since then and nurses to make sure we
were never overwhelmed
and i can tell you that the water
crested it got pretty close remember
pretty close
to the top of the bathtub but it never
overflowed
and at that point we're also thinking
about um
what more can we do to flatten the curve
and that took us to
looking at the folks flying in from
overseas we had virtually no testing
capacity at that time you probably
remember the cdc said um
what few tests you do send them down to
atlanta and a week later
you may get a response and it was longer
than a week later
and then uh soon thereafter they said
you can use your own
state lab and our lab could do maybe 20
tests a day so let's say we are
really um being tight about you know
testing people who came in from wuhan
then as we expanded our
mix a little bit more broadly we were
able to start testing people with
symptoms or at least first responders
with symptoms
because we really had to make sure that
nurses could get back to the icus nurses
would keep showing up at the
nursing homes where we needed help food
service workers and others who were just
getting scared out of their minds
and we could have had a total shutdown
and we had to do everything we could to
give people confidence going forward
and one of the things we needed to give
people confidence
was to bring in folks from business
and the healthcare community i
did my best to interpret what i was
hearing from
um indra and albert but uh that's what
we needed and we had a david shearer and
a few folks
some spontaneous group of healthcare
professionals were beginning to
think about what we had to do and we
brought them into the mix and we had
probably
um 20 leading health care professionals
uh everything from dr koh and
epidemiologists to folks who focused on
testing who folks
focused on therapies um to start off
and our job was to lead with the science
as justin said
and what i tried to do was explain what
we were doing in layman's terms
i could not do this by fiat i could not
just order people wear the mask and stay
safe stay home or else i'm going to
arrest you i had to
do the best i could to convince people
that
the very best minds we could lean on
we're strongly saying this is a life or
death
and if you're talking to a young person
who are maybe a little more casual
and invincible this is life or death for
your parent or your grandparent who
you're living with
and do the best we could to convince
people this was the right thing to do
and uh connecticut was very responsive
there
early on at the same time we had to do
in terms of the mass
we're all pretty socially distanced so
uh the dean said i could take my mask
off for just this
brief um moment um
there was no um supply down in
washington dc you probably heard don't
worry the cavalry's on the way it's
going to come up from
you know the supply depot in washington
there was nothing there
and we went to our hospitals first of
all and they had maybe a two-week supply
of mass and gowns that at that point
were focused on vents
and uh at that point you had 50
governors
um scrambling doing the best we could to
find where we could get
in particular the mass because it was
potential that our
economy and our society shut down if
people did not feel safe
and if we couldn't get the mass we we
couldn't stem the tide
and um you know josh fortunately had
had some work in the scientific
community so we're able to locally uh
source
a lot of the um ppe that we needed
but uh that was not enough and there was
a scramble and there was one state
competing against each other
and we'd have this stuff ordered and
it'd be landing at the airport and then
like
zoom pricing on uber the plane would
take off and go to a place where they
had had a higher
um offer for the same pp and uh at that
point um
i i think back to mike pompeo what he
said about
china in his dismissive way and we had
to fight
we realized that um connecticut and
america don't
have control over their own supply chain
especially when it comes to
uh um at that point it was ppe
later on we can talk about antibiotics
or we can talk about other things where
we need control
and there we reached out to our friends
in the business community in the
political community and got some
relationships with china
and um you know chartered the plane the
plane was about to take off china shuts
down the border um
finally we got it to san francisco the
trucks got lost in the way here to
connecticut and finally um
finally at a nice day in late april
early may we're all there with the
nurses and
first responders cheering as the tractor
trailer trucks
came in with the ppe that we needed
to survive at the same time
we wanted to think about what happens
next
and that's when um you know my dear
friend indranui had
been such a help to the state all along
the way she was helping with economic
development stepped up and said um i
think i know some people i think i can
help us get
restarted and um you may think gosh it
was a little funny time to be thinking
about restarting um
you know we were um you know
we had the fatalities on a daily basis
i'd be uh
you know doing the tv press conference
every afternoon
and everybody was glued wondering what
was happening next as we
but we're also thinking about um what
does happen next
and how we slowly get back to a new
normal and first we had to think about
how we um
closed things down and uh that
was actually the people the folks at
connecticut were ready they knew what we
had to do by the time i closed down the
schools
90 had already closed by the time i uh
closed down um
stores and hair salons and restaurants
um
people were already voting with their
feet and not wanting to show up
um it was a little tougher with bars
actually guys
the bars were were packed st patrick's
day and then it was the very next day
that
we had to uh close those down but soon
thereafter um
you know with indra and the team of uh
small business people that she put
together and folks from the association
we're also thinking about how you can
open
and open safely and you know there
um you know albert indra and i would
have some you know real debates because
shut it down stay closed let's wait
until we're 100
safe let's wait until we have a vaccine
you know only then can you open but you
people were getting a little frisky and
it was spring and they'd been locked up
for an awful long time
and um so we had to give people a sense
of direction uh that we were on the way
um there was a way out of here and
that's why on may 20th was the first
time that albert
you know said look they're bringing the
infection right down we flattened the
curve
i think you can begin to do you can
begin to slowly reopen
some things so we did some of the stores
uh in outdoor dining just to get a small
sense of normalcy back to what we were
trying to accomplish
and the good news is that i think our
reopen committee
we did it right and people believed that
they were doing it right
so they were voluntarily following all
the guidance and protocols that we had
put in place
and ever since that may 20th day when we
started reopening
our infection rate as a state has been
going down uh virtually um
every week thereafter and as uh you know
peter said we're
fortunately one of the very few states
that um have an infection rate in and
around
one percent uh that has been over the
last uh you know 90 days
uh you know that said um that's when
people start getting casual
and that's when we started worrying and
that's when i saw um they reopened too
soon in places like texas
and florida and arizona and uh all of a
sudden you saw a hockey stick and it
ramp up
so you had to balance the good news
going on in connecticut
with the risks that you saw elsewhere
and do as best we can to explain that to
people
in a way that they could understand so
they would voluntarily follow the
protocols
so they would wear the mass even though
they didn't necessarily think they had
to
and there i got to tell you um
uh connecticut's been a leader i mean
we're more likely to wear the mask than
just about any state in the uh
country and um that's made an enormous
difference
and we put in place an advertising
campaign um
and just friends from omnicom helped us
with that and i was getting you know
do i have to wear the mask outdoors if
not within five feet of people what if
i'm in a screened-in porch
what happens if i'm inside or just with
my closest friends
and we came up with a motto if you have
to ask
where the mask and uh and that resonated
and made a difference i'm going to
leave you with um you know one last
thought
which is uh you're all here at the
school of public health
and this may be uh your opening week and
um
i didn't really understand public health
the way i should have a year and a half
ago when i took office and i think i
told you what were the risks i was
focusing on given my background
and thankfully um there are a lot of
folks smarter
than me in our state government and uh
we have deirdre gifford who came out of
hhs and we had matt carter who's
affiliated here in our department of
public health working to catch up
and then state government can't do it
all working with the scientific
community
working with albert coe working with
jackson labs working with uconn health
we were able to do this but i would urge
each and every one of you
if you're thinking about what you want
to do along the way um
we got internship programs for you
department of public health and a career
thereafter
because this is the beginning of
something not the end of something
and we need you more than ever thank you
governor lamont
that was a terrific review of where
we've been
many of us in the audience went with you
on this journey
i think our dean of our school of
medicine nancy brown
who's here in the front row had been on
the job
for four weeks
she started the first of february
anne kurth took responsibility dean of
our school of nursing
took responsibility for a lot of the ppe
crisis uh here on campus so
uh we we we took a role in in contact
tracing the school public health so
we've been
with you from the start of this and uh
we're very proud of our school of public
health
students who were quickly joined by
school of medicine school of nursing
students
who served as a 200 person uh
volunteer uh group doing contact racing
for the city of new haven
so on that note you've already answered
the first question that's being posed to
you so i'm gonna
i'm gonna evolve that many of us thought
that your regional approach
where you and your fellow governors from
delaware to massachusetts
um sort of started to own that i-95
amtrak corridor and tried to synergize
your responses could you comment just a
little further on that you mentioned it
but i'd love to hear
how that came about
uh two things i'd say one
there was no help what was coming out of
washington d.c and the white house
and clorox and mass for wimps and
a lot of missed signals and uh so
we as fellow governors said we have a
pretty good bully pulp but we wanted to
speak with one voice in terms of what
you have to do from a
public health point of view and dean
also
he realized i realized there's a
relatively small state next to
massachusetts and
new york that um i could close my bars
but that doesn't
make any difference if cuomo and baker
leave their bars open you got people
driving back and forth
that's even a lot more dangerous so we
tried to do when it came to closing down
was
speak with one voice that allowed us to
better explain to people what we are
trying to do
and kept people closer to home excellent
and along with your chief of staff the
two representatives to that multi-state
task force were in fact
our reopened connecticut co-chairs uh
albert koh and indra nuri who are with
us today
and i wanted to ask how did the reopen
connecticut advisory group
approach its mission there you were
given that you were given
the mandate by the governor how did you
organize yourselves and think about this
in the kind of strategic
response that that you embraced and
came out in your report so when um the
governor called me i think on a saturday
and said
i want you to co-share this with albert
cole i'd only seen albert on zoom i'd
never met him
really didn't know him so i came up on
sunday morning to the yale school of
medicine
and albert taught me the basics of
public health and epidemiology
it was like a multi-hour lecture because
you can't really co-chair something with
an epidemiologist
and make decisions or recommend
decisions for the state
without understanding a little bit of
the science of the epidemiology
so it's very very important that first
meeting that albert and i had
and very soon we realized that the
shutdown was a suppression of the virus
and the longer you suppress the harder
it was going to be to come out of
suppression because had we stayed
suppressed for a year
economic activity would have struggled
massively and we wouldn't know how to
come out
of the shutdown so there was a critical
intermediate point where we had to dial
between public health
and economic health and when we decided
that we have to prioritize economic
health and sometimes and
public health and other times we also
had to make sure that
anything we opened had the appropriate
safety protocols
so the big discussion that albert and i
were leading with the team
we recruited the best and the brightest
of scientists business people
it was amazing how many people
volunteered to be on this
reopen committee quit their jobs
temporarily to work on this committee
and i think we worked
you know 18 hours a day for about six to
eight weeks
but everybody worked as a team and we
worked with josh and dave lehmann and
the governor
and what was amazing is they understood
the science
and it was a wonderful partnership where
we all worked together to decide
how best to dial these to public health
and economic
health of the state and get to the right
point where
you stay suppressed for a while and
slowly you start to open up
the right protocols so you don't have
another outbreak
that was a dance that was most difficult
to execute
so we went sector by sector put in
protocols
for opening and then for slowly ramping
up
and i think that's what served us in
good stead the fact that we could
recommend something
with a clear mind objective and then the
state
took our recommendations and modified it
for the state because
what we did did not really look at the
realities on the ground in the state
so the state then took it up and said
this is what we think makes sense this
doesn't make sense let's modify it so
there's a wonderful partnership between
the reopen connecticut advisory group
and the state
i don't know about what you want to add
because albert really was the uh
star of the whole reopen connecticut
because without albert's input
i don't think we could have had a
reopened connecticut task force
albert and i i really don't have much to
add i think that captured
the the the vision in the mission of the
reopening connecticut and of course this
was
this was um calibrated together with
you know people from the governor's
office the governor himself josh
you know josh javal david lehman i think
the couple things that
came out of this that was just to add
was that um
you know what made this different from
other states
was first of all it was done early i
think we were
ahead of the curve in terms of other
states and in what the governor said
thinking about how you're going to
reopen
you know we were at the peak of the
epidemic but thinking proactively
uh the second thing was that it was
multidisciplinary
um you know indra with her vision
brought in not only
the public health in the uh the business
and the economy but also the education
and the social you know the societal the
sports the education
the um uh the social services
all together until one one um part so it
was this
i think it got at this idea of
well-being rather than public health and
what differentiated i think connecticut
was that we put well-being ahead whereas
other states just led with either public
health or they led with
one of the sectors like like business
and i think that's how we got
that that special formula and i think
that we're a tiny state as
as the governor said but when we first
started
we were looking at other states to see
how well they were doing their reopened
plans because
every state was setting up a reopened
committee but as we reached about the
five or six week mark
most states are calling us to say what's
connecticut doing because we like your
approach
so clearly uh the expert team we
assembled together was doing
a very good job and thinking through the
reopen and when the protocols were
published on how to reopen the state
some of the states that i was looking up
to like utah were calling and saying
can we borrow connecticut's protocols
you guys have the best protocols for
opening schools or colleges or
restaurants or whatever i said look it's
all on ct.gov you can have it all it's
really for humanity not necessarily for
connecticut
so i think that this partnership between
the reopened connecticut team and the
governor's office really worked well
you know i read the book the great
influenza by john barry
the last chapter of that book was
profound it really talked about
what needed to happen he talked about
a leader should be driven by science but
apply judgment
they should speak to the media honestly
without creating panic they should make
sure that they understand the economic
side and the
health side everything i read about in
that last chapter of the book
i think connecticut practiced if you
watched the governor's press conferences
they were honest fact-based
science-based but they didn't create
panic
so i think we were in many cases
thanks to you governor a bit of a
textbook on how
we might want to approach i hope we
never have another pandemic but we could
write a playbook for ourselves so thank
you
excellent and what a great transition to
uh director marissa bond head of
our health department right here in our
city of new haven
um you know that there have been
overwhelming challenges well documented
within the health sector
what uh dean brown and her counterpart
dean liang up at uconn faced with
marna bargstrom and her counterparts uh
leading
uh the health systems and hospitals and
clinics of the
the state um are are really um
it was a it was a it was a terrible
story at the same time
the health system rose to the occasion
managed to
get the ppe managed to care for the
patients managed to do their very best
to keep the death rates to a minimum but
what about the public health
system what challenges you faced
are not as well documented not as widely
appreciated
what were the greatest challenges in the
city of new haven
uh in your role as the new director of
the department of health and you just
walked in
as the mayor did and were hit by this
what were
some of your principal challenges in the
months of uh march and april
yeah so you know as you mentioned i was
the new appointed
health director uh my official first day
was
the 27th of january and i get a call
from
the mayor on the 26th about a
presumptive um
potential case of a symptomatic
individual that was visiting
from overseas and needed to be isolated
and then tested
so that was my first day so my first day
has been for the last seven months to
really
respond to to covid and
you know as a public health practitioner
not being new to public health
but being back in the city that even
inspired me to be in
um in this sector um we have not seen
this form
of pandemic in over a hundred years
right so as public health practitioners
we know it in theory we want to prepare
and activate and the reality is that our
public health infrastructure has been
dismantled over the last few decades
that we needed to figure out an
infrastructure relatively quickly
um and one of the things that um you
know the the mayor
did as a collective is that we wanted to
activate a unified command
approach um this needed to be a team
effort
with multi-sectors involved and
different lens
that included not just the government
partners but external partners
and realizing that that was going to be
the great
the best way to try to box in this
pandemic and so it really consisted of
you know i i love every point that was
shared earlier you know
the mayor shared earlier about
addressing inequities
and seeing how this pandemic early on
um started exacerbating the inequities
of
specific subgroups and how do we then
create public health interventions for
those groups
how are we going to be transparent and
be forthcoming with the information and
early on not only was the governor
sharing
their weekly updates but we want to at
the local level be very specific and
transparent so the mayor was
wanted we did a daily presser and we
wanted to provide
daily updates to our local community on
what we're doing
what our cases look like in our city and
what interventions are in place and
available
that was really important and i loved
the governor's comment about there's no
borders
and we were very conscious of that like
what's happening what are other cities
doing and so not only did the mayor
communicate with
other local mayors we were communicating
with other local health directors
on sharing resources because we really
needed to maximize
the existing resources and build an
infrastructure that was going to be
sustainable
well that's terrific to hear about the
regionalization even at the city level
you were thinking about the region and
communicating
uh with a central command so that was
terrific
so good opportunity to turn it over to
the mayor um
you of course have been in the office
for a couple months
when this hit uh seems to be a recurring
theme here
and uh you've been credited for making
some very
firm and tough decisions early in the
pandemic response
communicating them very clearly and very
honestly
and uh i don't know how people in the
audience feel but i was very impressed
with your response
however in a leadership position like
yours
with the benefit of hindsight you're
bound to have
one or two or three things that you
might have done differently and we would
love to hear from you
sort of thinking about what what what
lessons learned
what might you have done even more
effectively in the month of say
uh february march uh to
to stem the disaster of april um
i would have hired director bond earlier
for starters she started working the day
before she started working which is uh i
appreciate that
and i and i have to admit and i'm sure
many people
have thought about if only we knew um
i think from time to time i should have
ordered 10 000 and 95 mass in january
right i'm sure our procurement
team would be like why are you doing
that but now that we know
um there's a lot of things that we would
have done
differently do you remember when we
started wearing masks and we're talking
about how masks don't protect you they
protect other people
and now there's a lot of evidence that
says that they protect you as well
um those are things that i think we all
experience together i i think
that um we will be uh
thinking for uh many years to come of
could we have saved lives by doing uh
certain things differently that
that we should have known to do
differently and
um and i know director bonn and i have
talked a lot about this and
i think one area that we might have
approached a little bit differently is
nursing homes
and again it's hard in hindsight to um
or it's easy in hindsight to
uh say we would have done some things
differently but
we lost a lot of people in nursing homes
and uh
you know i visit a number of the nursing
homes on a regular basis
and every time i go it it's very
emotional because
of um you know
the residents holding signs for events
saying i'm a survivor
and you implicitly know that so many of
their
uh their
neighbors did not survive and uh
and and i think that there are things
that we could have uh potentially done
to help protect those individuals more
again it's in hindsight but i think that
you know these types of decisions will
weigh on many of us for
uh for a long time thank you
um you're absolutely right that was an
immense challenge and
i believe this the latest statistic is
60 63
of all the deaths in the state were
attributable to folks in
in nursing homes and assisted living
we're back to the governor uh you had
your break governor now we're putting on
the spot
connecticut hosts 169 discrete
municipalities
and assuming that this level of
decentralization is
challenging for effective pandemic
control
how have you and the state worked
efficiently
with this number of towns and cities
in lieu of what is a more traditional
kind of state structure working with a
larger county structure
well i'll tell you first off new haven
was a star performer
new haven was a star performer in terms
of
just the percentage of people that got
tested and how important that was and
and you may think
yeah it's just a matter of having more
mobile vans and more people get tested
or making it free or more people to get
tested but
you really have to explain every day how
important i mean we would go to um
you know amy african-american churches
where folks are a little less likely to
want to get tested you get tested you um
lose your job or you have to sit out for
two weeks what happens and
and um you know justin director bond did
just a heck of a job of convincing
people the importance what it means to
your family what it means to your
community
but you're right dean i mean we got 169
towns and
uh it's the most incredibly inefficient
structure
and yet connecticut is proud of its
feisty independence um
you know we're trying to manage the
track and trace through
uh public health departments it's
working really well in new haven
you've been a leader there and obviously
a lot of the smaller towns
they need more guidance they need more
coaching and sometimes they need more um
you know expertise there to make it
happen we don't have a county form of
government so it it'd be easier to
manage on a top-down basis
but i think given the urgency that
people felt and josh's leadership um
even the track and trace which is
primarily being done on that local basis
to be done effectively
and when you have a one percent
infection rate it's a little easier to
track and trace everybody too
got it thanks uh let's turn it back
to uh our co-chairs indra and
albert um there is a question that came
in from the audience
that i thought i would throw in your
direction
um some models are suggesting
that there could very well be a surge of
cases
as early as november but possibly in the
traditional
viral respiratory season of december
through
through march and none of us know if
that's going to happen and
much of its behavioral mediated it may
be that people in connecticut are more
efficient at
controlling and it won't happen but
let's just say
that we start to see a surge
this winter how might the response
differ from what our experience was
in march and april
okay so so i think a couple caveats to
that question uh
so as we're seeing in spain
italy france right now you don't need to
invoke a winter season
you know to have a significant uh surge
and so the the the risk of a surge is is
with us
irrespective i think of a season now
we're particularly concerned about
what's going to happen in the winter
season
you know the the outdoor restaurants are
going to close
we're going to have people more spending
uh spending more time indoors
there's going to be higher contact rates
inside
closed closed encounters and then we
also have the specter of
influenza we already have you know
influenza
seasonal influenza peaks that take put
our health care systems into surge
crisis uh
quite quite often so so i think the
touch points or the pressure points
coming up into the winter season are
increased contact rates we're reopening
our schools
the second would be the cold cold
weather people having more context so
what are
what we're going to do differently and
let me just say i think there are two
heroes in this story
the first heroes are i think the
governor's team the office the people in
department of public health many of
these people are our alumni
from the yale school of public health
i'm thinking about kristen soto who
stood up the the contact tracing program
thinking about
people like matt carter who's uh who's a
faculty
in our department of epidemiology
microbial diseases deidre gifford
who um you know i think one of the
unfortunate things we have really
you know thing we have um things that
really
open our hearts what you know the kind
of the response is we have also seen
things like last weekend where where our
commissioner of health
you know received threats because of um
i think sound evidence-based decisions
about
you know stopping stopping football but
getting back
on track i think the you know those
those are
those are one set of heroes and they're
doing their job and i think they've
they've actually the governor's office
and i'd uh include josh
jabel and uh and michelle gilman who are
really implementing
you know sound policies they're getting
us ahead of the curve
and proactively whether it's
immunizations for influenza whether it's
getting up testing capacity
uh maximizing the opportunity to contain
so that's very different from
the situation we were you know back back
in back in march
i think the second thing is that in
which i i i i thought was remarkable and
probably the unsung heroes are the
citizens of uh
of connecticut you know they're wearing
the face masks
they're socially distancing we see these
metrics whether it's
you know you know through through
different you know contact phone
contact rates between cell phones the
citizens of
of of connecticut really have
taken social distancing and all their
public health prevention to heart
and and i'm not sure we really
understand why that is and why
you know connecticut is different from
georgia or florida or even
even delaware pennsylvania but i think
we're
that is certainly different from when we
were
we were before you know at the in march
or february
you know at the at the start start of
the epidemic so
i think with sound policies
evidence-driven policies
policies which go beyond what is
you know expected you know from the cdc
or from the federal government
but i think that's been that's been what
we've seen in in connecticut
together with really the buy-in from the
population i think
we're going to you know the the
aspiration for us is through that
winter season to to be in containment
mode
you know uh rather than having to be
you know in a reactive mode to
resurgence
albert and i were teaching a class at
som last weekend and a
class with healthcare professionals and
there was a student a practicing student
from
san antonio texas and he was the first
guy to ask questions and he said
we're struggling in san antonio we all
look to connecticut to see
how well you guys did the reopen that
was a big compliment
and so he said he's brought his wife and
daughter to show them connecticut
because
the state is doing so well i think
it's a good story overall excellent
thank you
i'm going to turn it back to uh director
bond
um you know in cut you mentioned that
the
infrastructure for public health in the
state
has not kept up with need and there was
a there was an immediate
uh demand both at the state level and at
the local health department level
to um recreate structures that may have
been in place 30 years ago but were not
in place the present time one of those
is contact tracing would you comment
on your partnership the partnerships in
april
that you used for immediate response and
what you with the state have done
uh now in september no absolutely so
one of you know as mentioned we had to
really talk about how we're going to box
in this
this pandemic so now that we had this
you know we were doing testing we were
isolating quarantining individuals
the way that works is utilizing a
contact tracing model
and we didn't have a system in place
when we
started the contact tracing so it was
more informal
in realizing we had public health
nursing nurses
or epidemiologists we knew that the
cases were greater than the staffing
structure that we had
and so we created a partnership with the
yale school of public health
where we then created a infrastructure
and expanded
upon what we were doing and it was it
was it was such a great success
because it allowed us to be able to then
engage
public health students medical students
nursing students
to then take theory that they're
learning in their coursework
and then apply it to a live pandemic and
be able to support
um our our contact tracing efforts and
it was so instrumental
in being able to mitigate the pandemic
in our city
and you know fast forward um what did
that do we
you know the state rolled out a contact
tracing
model across the state and so what we
wanted to do at the local level is be
complementary to what was being rolled
out at the state level because we wanted
to make sure that everything was
consistent and standardized
that is the only way we are going to be
able to successfully
do that and so we then pretty much
transition into the state model where
we're now um having
a a couple of ways that we're addressing
it we're still using uh volunteers but
medical reserve corps
and staff still to roll it out across
the state so it's been really successful
um
and you know initially realizing that
we needed to have this infrastructure
that was going to um
be able to address an immediate need but
then recognizing
the importance of standardization to it
to be consistent with other
local health and state health department
efforts
excellent thank you
i'm going to get a little parochial now
with the mayor
how does the city view yale's reopening
because here yale university uh is
in the heart of downtown new haven
bringing students from i don't know how
many states
let's just say 45 states and 45
countries
uh all back you know in
in in the month of august early
september
how do you see yale and its
uh response and the way it's a reopening
i i just wanted to first make a quick
comment on
the contact tracing because it was so
vital uh our partnership in particular
with the school of public health
uh to uh being quite successful at
identifying cases and ensuring there was
an additional spread
and it got a lot of attention and it's
it's funny uh
our communications person said all the
the bbc's reached out to uh
uh to talk to the city and i said oh
it's great i've never been interviewed
by bbc
before and our communication person said
no actually they want to talk to
director bond
and there was consistently things like
that because uh
the support in the relationship that we
had with the school of public health
in particular on that contract tracing
program was something that was hugely
helpful in new haven but also was
something that
um my hope is because we got a lot of
attention
and press on this that many other
communities were able to benefit from
that model as well
on your specific point about reopening
uh
we've been uh very um happy with the
approach that the university
um has taken as uh to reopening
uh peter and i had conversations about
the importance of reopening because of
what you both talked about of well-being
and not just
uh using that uh keeping every person
healthy from covid perspective because
there's so many other
reasons that we need to keep our overall
society healthy
that lead to other health impacts if
people don't have jobs if they don't
have homes if they don't have a steady
income
there's all kinds of additional health
impacts and thinking about this pandemic
from
a wider angle about the economic impacts
and what they can do to the health of
our community
is something that i think is vital to
our success and the university
i think understood the importance of
opening up in a cautious
and very thoughtful way but they
understood the importance of it and
that's everything from
the quarantine period that you've
instigated
the very very robust testing regime
the uh very serious
um this the students in the university
taking very very seriously
not having parties not congregating
we've seen what happens when that
doesn't
take place in other universities and how
that impacts not just the students but
the community at large
and so we've been very grateful that the
university has been willing to open
because new haven's economy is deeply
reliant
on the the university and people
physically being here
but doing it in a way that um up till
now has
kept us very very safe and the cases
have been very very low uh
and and so i i just want to underscore
when you think about
there's so many stories about the
universities we've been very happy with
how things have been going
cheer that peter some good news for yale
for a change
i'm how's that kidding so
thank you mayor it's a real appreciate
partnership and
trying to do the right thing for campus
and for our
surrounding community appreciate your
support and partnership in all of this
absolutely well i can't believe that our
time is coming to a close
uh because i have more than a dozen uh
questions from the audience that we're
not going to get to so
i apologize to everybody who won't get
their question answered but i'm going to
end with the governor
and i'll end with a clustering of a few
of those questions
so one questioner asked where is the
federal
coveted relief money for local health
departments
and another questioner asks when will
connecticut really highlight the
critical role
of local health departments and provide
more
funding and more consistent funding
commensured with their responsibilities
and another a questioner asks
what will there this new national
dialogue
on the dangers of continuing to
underfund public health in our country
when how will that translate at the
state and local level
and they the the questioner ends with a
commentary
local public health officials and
workers on the front lines
need our support protection advocacy so
throw that to you
sir well we got our covent relief money
and uh i think more than any other state
correct them if i'm wrong josh we've
allocated a higher percentage of it to
test it than anybody else
working closely with our local
departments of public health
you've been right on the front lines of
this and and if uh
as i suggested early on i have an
absolute new appreciation for how
important what each and every one of you
are going to be doing
in our local departments of public
health and
i just want you to remember one thing
because i have to remind
everybody all the time probably you less
so we're not out of the woods yet
and uh as you heard you know dr koh say
um you wanna know what i've been worried
about i mean i think k
through eight i think we can do that
that's a narrow cohort uh peter
i'm obviously a little more worried
about colleges like the dean said we're
coming from all over the region higher
infection areas
yale and our colleges have done it
really well a guy named rick levin maybe
you heard of him you know he'll put
together
our college committee and we've been
testing very thoughtfully on that
was people start going inside like dr
koh said i think november
will be a period of risk so my job is to
make sure that we keep our disciplines
something connecticut has
really led the country in and make sure
we realize that this is really a
very crucial you know 60 90 days coming
up
and um and and that's something
an urgency i have to repeat and uh but
more specifically your question i have a
new
fond appreciation of each and every one
of you
what you do how important you are going
forward i'm afraid this is not
um a 10 year or 100 year phenomenon it's
going to be more frequent than that we
got to be ready
and the public health and public safety
are side by side is our top priorities
thank you to you governor to you mayor
to our
heroes of the reopened connecticut
advisory group to our local hero
director bond thank you to all of you
appreciate deans uh
brown and kurth joining us josh chabal
from the state but most importantly our
school of
public health students this was an event
that was conceptualized
by albert and the governor
on your behalf to recognize you and your
uh future contributions to this
discipline thank you peter
and i bid you a good day
thank you everyone